[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie you've all
probably heard about Kevin Smith's story
about how he found out about a secret
Justice League trilogy of films that
we'll never get to see so I'm gonna play
this clip from him explaining what that
trilogy was then we'll break it down
because there are some big changes you
may remember when we knew that they were
gonna be to Justice League films but
apparently the original plan was for
them to do a full trilogy we're still
doing that Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Justice League
moment on the video so here's the clip
of Kevin Smith explaining what that
trilogy was and all those deleted scenes
and story arcs I met people who worked
on both versions of Justice League
isn't that yeah let me tell you the
things that I learned they saw Jim Lee
break down boards for all three Justice
League movies really first movie mmm was
kind of what we saw fight and
Steppenwolf meet and Steppenwolf then
like the [ __ ] boom tube opened up and
they saw dark side and dark side saw
them there was a mini scuffle or not
depending on who you're talking to boom
tube closes that's the end of the
[ __ ] movie with them all knowing
there's something out there we have to
go Justice League to was going cosmic as
they take the fight to apocalypse and
New Genesis presumably but we know
apocalypse and the Lantern Corps was
involved because do you remember that
shot of Alfred going like thank god
you're here let's hope you're not too
late and everyone was like oh that's
Superman because the S is the hope and
[ __ ] like that guy I met and talked to
worked on the set was like we had green
lights that were flashing on Jeremy
Irons to project the green glow I said
why he goes because it was Green Lantern
can you [ __ ] imagine but then things
changed in production and what was the
third movie the third movie was two ends
poorly like Empire Strikes Back war
infinity war so they go to space and get
[ __ ] defeated and the dark side goes
to earth and levels it so the vision
that Batman had in Batman V Superman
like you know of the [ __ ] scorched
shirt which which one was that was a BB
suit BB yes sir yes where he saw the
[ __ ] scorched earth and IRA demons
internship that was going to be the
entire third movie the heroes last stand
against Darkseid and the forces of
apocalypse so it went from three movies
to two to now just the one to half a one
they had a beep where he saw like Gimli
drew it out he's like so you could see
and these cats are in special effects so
they had to be able to like what are we
doing
yes so they saw the beat board like the
story kind of laid out and that that was
an epic vision but it sounds like a bit
of a panic decision so as you guys
listen to that doesn't it sound like
their original plan was to hit a lot of
those big Star Wars original trilogy
beats like they literally called their
second movie their empire strikes back
with a downer ending then they rally in
the final film for their last stand
most of our common knowledge goes back
to what their plan was for the two films
after they had apparently decided not to
do a full trilogy and most of those
changes in the story arcs and the
characters revolve around Superman's
character arc in darkseid's arc we
actually know a lot about the individual
story arcs and how much they change so
I'll explain that Kevin Smith didn't
really get into that he just kind of hit
the big beats so originally when it was
still a trilogy first movie picks up
Superman is still dead at the beginning
Steppenwolf still comes for the three
mother boxes Steppenwolf was always
going to come for the three mother boxes
but in the big flashback scene that they
have were the ancient gods
battling Steppenwolf originally it was
dark side that they were fighting the
union of the Atlanteans the Amazons the
humans in the gods defeat Darkseid and
they capture his three mother boxes so
Darkseid can't use them to just turn
around and conquer the planet again the
rest of history proceeds accordingly as
you all saw during the other solo movies
till the events of Batman V Superman in
the first Justice League film so
Superman still dead at the beginning
Steppenwolf is still the main villain of
the first film he comes back to earth
not because he wants to conquer it or
even cares about the earth in general
just because he wants to unite all three
mother boxes and free his mother Hydra
from the unity remember during the
theatrical cut of Justice League there
were all these weird lines of dialogue
that Steppenwolf had talking about the
mother boxes as if he was talking to his
mother
that's because his mother's spirit and
her power were literally inside the
mother boxes within the DCE you hegh row
was a super powerful new god that was a
rival of dark sides on apocalypse he
traps her life force in her power within
the three mother boxes so Steppenwolf in
present-day his dark sides uncle but has
always hated serving under him he's been
in exile and he wants to seize
apocalypse for himself so he wants the
mother boxes so that he can free his
mother's soul take her power to defeat
Darkseid and take over apocalypse
himself so this is whole running
plotline of Steppenwolf versus Darkseid
in the background why you have all the
main storyline Justice League vs
Darkseid stuff happening the first movie
continues on Superman still comes back
to life Pet Sematary style but he
originally comes back without his
memories so he goes full Kryptonian on
the Justice League and they spent a lot
more of the plot fighting what seems
like an evil Superman before they're
able to use Lois to bring him back to
his senses remember the future version
of the flash coming to Batman in that
vision from Batman vs Superman
that scene was all about setting up the
lowest bombs that Batman drops on
Superman during Justice League it was
just much more drawn-out during the
movie rest of the plot relatively
similar the Alfred scene with Green
Lantern appearing sounds like it
happened right as the Justice League
were arriving at Steppenwolf's converted
base enough time for him to make it
there and help them deal with the three
mother boxes before Steppenwolf could
free his mother Hegira Superman still
helps them defeat Steppenwolf at the end
of the movie but the other
big changes to the ending of the
original movie was that when the final
boom tube opens to apocalypse to take
Steppenwolf back the Justice League
looks through the portal and sees dark
sides face letting them know that
there's a bigger threat out there so the
movie ends with them making the decision
like Kevin Smith says to go to
apocalypse and face him preemptively
rather than sit around and wait for
Darkseid to come for them you all may
remember that they just did that exact
same scene during the animated reign of
the Superman movie there's a scene at
the end where the Justice League decides
to go to apocalypse and fight Darkseid
before he can come for them now I kind
of wonder if they added that to the
animated movie because they weren't
gonna do it during the live-action
trilogy version like well they're not
gonna use it will borrow that story beat
second movie as Kevin Smith said is the
Justice League mostly on apocalypse
facing Darkseid and his minions with the
added help of Hal Jordan in the Green
Lantern Corps
but as he goes on to say it was meant to
be there Empire Strikes Back
quote-unquote so they get their asses
handed to them by Darkseid
they're Return of the Jedi was gonna be
Darkseid coming back to Planet Earth and
using the anti-life equation to turn
Planet Earth into the nightmare vision
so that's where a lot of the mind
controlled craziness was coming from in
that Batman V Superman vision that he
had the Justice League makes their last
stand defeats dark side and then what's
not clear from what Kevin Smith says is
how that third movie ends if they just
continue forward and help the earth
rebuild or if the flash goes back in
time and changes things so that they can
defeat Darkseid before he uses the
anti-life equation on planet Earth so
either way you can tell it was meant to
be a very Star Wars original trilogy in
the way a lot of the beats played out
but Kevin Smith's kind of goes on to
speculate and I think he's correct when
he says that what Warner Brothers saw
the divisive reaction to Batman V
Superman's opening weekend they
immediately decided to pull the trilogy
back to a sequel like bowling they do
two films instead of three meaning that
it kind of broke the film's because they
had already started production on
Justice League before Batman V Superman
hit theaters so like the Train is
already moving down the tracks it's
really hard to change big big story
beasts that you've been planning out for
a long time so as things continue they
still have that two movie plan but
things get worse with Batman V Superman
in the public
action so Warner Brothers says fine
we're just gonna do one film at this
point breaking the narrative even more
meaning they had to make even more
changes and more story edits so already
things were kind of a mess then Zack
Snyder had all those unfortunate
personal problems that he had to deal
with Joss Whedon comes on changes the
movie again just because there are
certain story beats that he just isn't
really happy with and you get what we
actually saw in theaters so it is a
crazy story of what that originally was
I would love to see some of those Jim
Lee's storyboards but they're probably
never gonna let those see the light of
day right now Warner Brothers still
plans on eventually making more Justice
League films but their plans on how they
get there just have changed quite a bit
I did a video with patty Jenkins talking
about it that I'll add a link for at the
end of this but it sounds like what
they'll try the next time they do a
Justice League film is the roster will
be a little bit different because it
probably won't happen till after we get
a Green Lantern core inside the DCU
officially even though we kind of saw
one in that flashback scene whatever the
story of that Justice League movie is
it's kind of self-contained so that you
don't have to spend all the other solo
movies setting it up and they can be
relatively self-contained too so that's
really what they mean when they say the
films aren't crossing over as much
because it's still a connected universe
they'll still reference moments in other
films but just not in the really big way
that they did leading up to the original
Justice League movie that we saw in
theaters so everybody post your
reactions to that crazy story in the
comments below it's Super Bowl weekend
there's gonna be a whole bunch of
trailers they said that the next Shazam
trailer might not drop to the middle of
February so I'm not expecting new Shazam
footage this weekend while you wait for
everything you can click here to watch
patty Jenkins talk about the next
Justice League film Wonder Woman 1984
and Wonder Woman 3 and you can click
here for that brand new Captain Marvel
Super Bowl trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]